a brother's chief calling from Texas
what's up chief what up chief boy
and you notice fella probably huffing on
that bag you don't get the name chief
these days chief used to be a Native
American superior turn if you're a
captain of the Native Americans if you
basically this you know the Chris Pratt
Oh Joey if you's a real you know if you
that top dog in the in the feather in a
in that in that feather club then you
would get that name chief but more
recently chief is more of a okay you
know little Gary does a lot of chief in
that hey sucking on that gas bro puffing
at that goo goo that herb maybe that
that weed huffing that nasty nasty you
know he huffing that [ __ ] you know mr.
McGregor's gunpowder dog I'm talking
about marijuana I'm talking about that
puff puff I'm talking about that poor
pop to your brain that dope weed onward
I was watching the podcast the [ __ ]
ladies night one whatever the [ __ ] that
was yeah it was ladies night brother
onward watching that [ __ ] just now you
said what do you thinks gonna go away
and the near future talking about
pooping their Tim's taking [ __ ] like
that right we're talking about people
last on last episode we're talking about
people getting their temperatures taken
when you go to an event you know you go
somewhere and now in the future but they
might you know take your temperature
check if it's not they might you know
touch your kids low ass or something see
if it's hot see if you bring it in a
little Timothy or whatever with that hot
ass because that you can't do it you
can't do that there you're not gonna be
able to do that as well you bring in
that up temperature temp temp a--they
it's not gonna go over well with others
let's hear more brother thank you for
the call
what's gonna go
I think you know you're not from Texas
like I anger you know but there probably
had ten or fifteen Mexican restaurants
in Louisiana what's gonna go away though
is chips and queso and chips and salsa
sign that [ __ ] is done I mean that's not
gonna be on the menu no more son unless
you get it individually it's not an
appetizer no more you know what I'm
saying cuz what everybody is doing
they're getting the chips bring a chip
to the dip putting a straight in a mouth
going back to the chips going back to
the gift putting back straight in their
mouth
damn you know lean with it rock with it
huh no you can't sanitize every time you
touch a chip you know what I mean them
chips you're just gonna be too salty
after a while so so yeah all right Peter
all right be the queso insults that gang
gang gang bruh man wow I hadn't thought
about that yeah yeah you gonna have to
each person will have to bring a couple
of their own chips from home I guess and
you know or yeah uh yeah I don't know
what they're gonna do hmm
but yeah you can't have that group you
can't have that that that swimming pool
in the middle of the table you can't
have that little that little cheese
[ __ ] strip mall in the little of the
table and everybody's just scooping in
getting this picking up a pair of Adidas
or picking up a pair of uh you know
Motorola or something or get some
speakers or some [ __ ] Chinese food
that Chang chopped you know yeah they're
not gonna have that group that little
wah that little um they're not gonna
have that little where everybody's just
hands are in they're just that little
bang bang bang up there with the chips
hmm that's gonna be interesting man yeah
that could be one thing that could go
away now you got to bring a couple chips
from home or something you got to write
you know your name on the chip Darren
you know little Ricky and little Ricky
got four chips you know when Darren got
9 chips Darren's big-ass got 9 chips and
actor actor over there and you know he
got you know chips running his family so
he got 40
chips come on Hector no you have 40
chips bro shoot the 9 pointer papa but
yeah it's gonna be because everybody
yeah you're not gonna have be able to
have that that meeting that meet up in
the middle of the table that could be
something could change but evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was ok but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watch this one